all right one other quick thing i got i
have to i just i have to play this for
you i can't i can't not play it um tess
holliday is a plus size
model
is how she self identifies
and she also has recently we've i i
think we've mentioned this before a few
few months ago when the news came out
that tess holliday who weighed you know
she weighs
i
by the looks of it she weighs 350 plus
pounds and but she's she is she's
anorexic she says and so she was on a
talk show this week
talking about her
her battle with anorexia
um and here she is talking a little bit
about about overcoming and the courage
it took her to overcome anorexia listen
to this
i
i feel immense gratitude and pride that
i am able to sit here with you and talk
about such hard things and know that
there's somebody on the other side that
feels less alone that maybe says to
themself i'm gonna get help asks for
help uh starts taking care of themselves
in the way that they deserve because
you know plus size or not we all
everybody deserves food everybody
deserves to eat
you know
it's we deserve to take care of
ourselves we deserve to live without
judgment we do we do yes that's the
biggest thing in all of it are you
currently in therapy how often are you
yeah so um i see my dietitian once a
week and then i have my therapist once a
week
and i have a lot of people in my life
who lovingly just
nudge me nudge me along the right path
and
yeah i'm
doing it
she sees her dietitian once a week
uh might want to ask for a refund on
that
i mean in some ways you know it's it's
inspiring i think to see someone
who has so thoroughly beaten anorexia i
mean she has
dominated
and crushed her
anorexia um
this is a this is like mike tyson in his
prime
okay
that's how that's how much is a
first-round knockout of anorexia
um man
now look everything she's talking about
she she's uh
she says that you know uh talking about
eating disorders and people and she
needs it's okay to ask for help
all of that is all that's of course true
and um it is also true that you could
say that she has an eating disorder in
the
sense that
she's eating way way too much you know
in quite a disordered way in fact in a
self-destructive way
but that's not what she means okay
she actually she's claiming to have
anorexia
which by definition anorexia is you know
with
not eating you know keeping yourself
away from food to the extent that it
actually causes you to be you know
famished
where you're like starving yourself
that's what anorexia is
[Music]
and i yeah you can't judge a book by its
cover but i am pretty sure that tess
holiday is not starving
well i hope you enjoyed that clip for
the matte wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content